HOPPING
ANXIETY,AL T NORMAL.
ESPECIALLY ABOUT BUYING GIFTS
SINGLETAINCE
COLUMNT TOO THE AUTHOR OF WHAT
THIS EXCLUDES FOODNEWHEN  HITA .
DY.
AND HAPPY HOLIDAY TO YOU.ES.IGH.
>> IT'ON THIS -- $100
BASICALLY, YOU AREOING --  ALL
LISTT?
AND THEN YOU ARE GOING TO THINK
ABOUT THE KIS THAT
PEOPLE WANT.
HOW OFTEN, VICTOR, ARE YOUOKING
PHONE?
RIGHT?
YOU KNOW
THAL TH
THHO         HER WMEALS AND I OE
THREE GUESTS.
NEXT TIME YOU ARE IN D.C YNE OH
MONEY.E ME ANERM YI
WHAT DO YOU WANT TIME, BABY.
SHE SAID, HOW AB I HELP
DER  HYOU HAVE BEEN TALKING ABO
THAT?
YOUR ADULT CHILD BECAU
KNOW THEY ONLY WANT  SFIVE MINUR
ANE THAT.
ARENTS CAN TAKONTHEIR E,EC
GRDP GOT T PNE
TO THEIR'
FAVORITERYYOU
WEY WANTISHE PFOR  IF THEY ARE
SO THERE IS SOHI THE KING ABOUT
ADULTS HERE. ABOUT THE K
D AL AND ARE MAI ADGET AND SANTR
>> WEL YOU WE ARAN
RU
CHILDREN'S
EXPECTATIONS.
MY HUSBAND AND I WOULD
SANTA'S HAD A DIFFICULT TIME.
YOU OW ELVES DIDN'T SHOW
FOR WORK.
>> OH,GO
>>Y ., THE ELVES OP STRI?
Y COME ON.
U GE
OFF THE
WHEN THEY WERE IW E GOING L AT .
TTLE, LIKE
UNDER 3, I LOOK THROH R CLOSET T
BE P WITH ORBE
AND I WRAPD IT UP ANPU
UNDER EE.
>>ES, I DID.
>> NO. , YES.
LOVE UNWR S
AT REALLY ,
ULIKE
NGS ANAY THAEM ABILI
TOP STUFF ANHAT
FUN'T HAVE TO SP
THISHRAGO, BUTKA HAT THEADHA
THIS I INTO YO
PIECE ONTI SEVEN TIPS HERE.
I DON'T THINK I'VE EVER REGIFTED
ANYTHING.
HA PERSON INY LIFE WHOE LAST TEN
IM CAR STO GOOD WILL
I WANT TI  IT.
SOMETHING. YOUREGIFTING -- GO A.
>> I LOVE THAT YOUE
THAT, THAT'S GREATNER ARITY, HE
SOMEBODY OUT.Y YOU' PERSOAND
CHILD AND GYOU A PARTFOR YOU O
HE LOVES BOOKS.'T CARAT YOU DON.
NG CLOSS SET.EN THEY'RE LITTLE,T
OF H
I'VE GOT A TRUCK A THA
LIKES TRUCK.
YOU WRAP IT AND GIVE IT TOHA
KID.
WE HAVE H STUF OUR
HOMES, IN LID
HE THEIT WOULDS OFF OF ALWAYS F.
THEE OF REGTI
THE PWO
KE
MY BS A
I'ING TO GIVE HEA
PI
>> YTER
>> BETTER T,IGIFE T EARRINGS
AND YOU KNOWT'OKAY.WE DON'T H
WHERE I GOT THESFTS.
THAT YORE
EVERYTHING THAT YOU
THERE EEN TIMES THATU'N INVITEDG
AT THE LASMINUTE, BI
PARTY OROM
YOU HAVE SOMETNG OSET THAT'S NET
PERSON RULE.
DON' SUSPECT SOMEBOD YOU
SAKSHEYOBO.REGIFTING, DON'TUT
IT ACOSTCO.
THAT'S A GOOD THING.T TRY TO F.
LES THAT I KNOW PEOPLE
AND BUY
INGLETARY OFWASHINGTON POST," T